so I guess oh I guess I'll stir okay I'm
gonna talk about expected characteristic
for Romeo's and let's begin by recalling
what happened in the previous talk
previous talk yon showed that every
graph G has a Ramanujan signing and what
that means is the adjacency matrix
there's a way to put science so that the
norm of the signed my tricks is at most
is number two squared D minus one and
and there were two ingredients that went
into this proof
so one was something I'm gonna call
theorem a which was a certain real
rootedness statement about a large class
of polynomials which ended up including
matching polynomials and various
conditionings of them in this
interrelating are in argument so theorem
a was that if our one through our M are
independent random vectors
in RN so they're vector-valued random
variables are independent as random
variables not as vectors they're
independent random vectors in RN then
the expected characteristic polynomial
so the expected determinant of X I minus
the sum of the rank one matrices
corresponding to these vectors this
thing is real rooted so our army
interval who did that was one ingredient
that was used to show the existence of
these common inner lacings and the
second ingredient was the serum of Hyman
and liebe from 1972 which said that a
very specific polynomial that arose when
studying these signings the matching
polynomial of a graph add zeros bounded
by this magic number two squared B minus
one so the second eigenvalue of the
matching polynomial of a graph that's d
regular is bounded by this number two
Square D minus one so these are two of
the ingredients that went into the proof
and neither of these things was was
proven in the talk so the first thing
I'm going to do is show you the proofs
of these statements to complete the
proof that yarn discussed and I mean you
know these are different types of
statements this is a this is I think of
this is a qualitative statement it's
saying that some polynomial has real
roots it doesn't say anything about
where the roots are and it's a very
generic statement the second statement
this is a quantitative statement it's
it's sort of the first result we're
talking about today where you actually
prove something about the locations of
zeros or some concrete concrete
portfolio and so first I'll present
these and I'll discuss some algorithmic
issues as well as this proof of microcon
that there's a polynomial time algorithm
for finding revolution graphs that was
alluded to earlier so let me start by
talking about of this theorem a real
rootedness of expected characteristic
polynomials of sums of independent rank
one random matrices
okay so there are many ways to prove
this and here is here's one that's
that's pretty quick so let's assume for
simplicity this doesn't change anything
assume that the random vectors are I
each only take one of two values so
let's say this is RI plus with
probability some number of pi plus and
RI minus with probability VI - okay so
each of the random vectors has this
distribution and they're independent so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
evaluate
something that looks a bit like the
expected characteristic polynomial but
but not quite
it's a multivariate polynomial or I'm
just gonna add one variable for each of
these random vectors so consider this
polynomial and okay let's let's expand
it using the Cauchy Binet formula Rossa
Binet formula says that a determinant of
a sum of rank one matrices is the sum of
determinants of subsets of n of those
matrices if the matrices live in n
dimensions right so these are all random
vectors of our hand this is an N by n
matrix but they're M terms here because
if any formula says that well you can
break this into sum of determinants that
look like this index by subsets of size
n if you have a subset of the vectors
and now you just have the determinant
restricted to that subset
okay and now let's let's look at this
for a moment this is an N by n matrix
it's a sum of n rank one matrices and so
because the determinant is multi linear
in rank one matrices you can actually
just pull these the eyes out this is
actually equal to the sum so I'm going
to move the expectation in as well so
for each of these terms if I pull all
the Z variables out I get a Z to the
capital S and then I get the expectation
of the determinant sum of RI RI
transpose I in that subset
okay that's this is the this is some
polynomial that looks related to what
I'm interested in and I just expanded it
using cosy bunny any questions about
this so far okay on the other hand I'm
going to look at another polynomial
which which I'm going to be easily able
to show is is real stable okay so it's
not obvious what the properties of this
are but instead look at the polynomial
determinant of sum over I and M Zi
expectation of RI RI transpose so I push
the expectation inside
then this polynomial well this
polynomial is stable why because these
are covariance matrices which are
positive semi-definite and this is
actually a special case of the you know
mother of all stable polynomials which
and of the okay so now let's do the same
thing here right let's let's expand this
using the Kosovan a formula so what is
that so that's determinant so I have a
sum over my my random vectors each of
these expectations is itself a sum over
two things right because each each
vector only takes one of two values so
each of these matrices actually Rank 2
and it's literally equal to p i+ r i+
ri+
transpose plus VI minus RI minus RI
minus transpose and just explicitly
written down the covariance matrix ok
and now I'm going to Kosovan ate this
now it's slightly different here there
were M matrices and I have to choose n
of them at a time here there are
actually two M matrices and you know
they have a pattern so for each their m
random vectors they correspond to
variable Z 1 Z 2 up to Z M but for each
of them there are two possibilities plus
and minus
they're two choices phrase random vector
okay so when I coach it beneath this I'm
going to again get a sum over all
subsets of determinants of sums of n of
these things now how many ways are there
to choose n things out of 2m things will
to M to n but some of these are special
so some of these only choose each
variable once some of the other ways
will choose a variable twice so let's
isolate all the terms which would choose
each each variable at most once okay so
what do you get if you do that
well so you'll get Z to the S and what
will you get it so now you've chosen
some subset of these things s what will
you get in front of the yes well you'll
get you have one choice for each of
these vectors right so you'll actually
get summation over all let's say these
are signs in minus 1 1 to the minus plus
to the S so for each of these variables
you choose either plus or minus and then
you get the determinant of summation Zi
superscript s our is our is
okay but that's not everything right
these are only the these are only the
ways of choosing a subset of the terms
that correspond to powers of Z less than
1 I also have higher order terms in Z
the higher order terms in Z you know you
could have a Zi Zi squared right I'm
just gonna clump all that together this
higher order terms okay any objection so
far can everybody see that
oh yeah s is still card ness is now a
subset yes s isto s is a subset of M of
cardinality n so the cardinality is
because it's an N by n matrix what
happens in the Co should be a formula if
a now if you stared this a little bit
apply the same trick you can pull these
probabilities out and so you see this
term with probability the product of the
probabilities of choosing you know
setting you know are RI equal to R 1
equal to s 1 R 2 equal to s 2 and so on
this whole sum I mean if you pulled
these probabilities out and use the fact
that the random vectors are independent
this is actually literally just the
expectation of determinant of some PI NS
RI RI transpose was our reference
okay
so by saying that higher degrees C you
mean that some guys with something I was
squared yeah yeah so terms terms
containing a zi squared for some square
I've not done anything fancy I've
expanded both using Cauchy Bonet and
made one simple observation and I see
that I get actually the same thing but
here I get some higher order terms so
higher order terms just means containing
some Zi squared right okay so now what
do I do
I wanted to prove well okay I mean I
guess I guess I haven't completed the
proof but okay this polynomial is stable
and it's equal to this other polynomial
which is an expected not quite
characteristic polynomial plus higher
order terms so then that means that if
you take map of this whole board the
higher order terms go away
therefore this polynomial is also stable
the map is multi affine part if in case
you missed Chan's lecture okay any
questions about that I'm not completely
done but it's one more line to finish
the proof any any questions okay so how
do I finish the proof now so so so what
have I concluded I've concluded that I
mean I'm going to try this new thing of
using colored markers learned from
Shayan I've learned that this polynomial
is stable for any independent random
vectors R 1 to R M I'm now going to
apply it to a specific set of random
vector so apply so let's call this star
by the fact that this is stable to the
random vectors R 1 through RM so these
are now end up the same independent
random vector they started with but pad
them with some deterministic vectors
equal to the standard basis
okay what does that mean it means that
the expected determinant of summation Zi
RI RI transpose Plus now I have some
more variables summation X I II III
transpose is stable
okay now again I'm basically done I'm
just gonna substitute all the Z is to be
minus 1 and all the x i's to be X these
just become minus 1 this becomes what is
the sum of x times the standard basis
vectors have their transpose it's the
identity this is actually the expected
characteristic polynomial of X hi -
that's the whole proof right there are
there numerous ways to prove this but I
think this is the quickest one and since
we already introduced map which is the
same thing we used to prove real
rootedness of the matching polynomial or
just use the same thing to prove this so
this is a very useful operator there's a
lot of okay so that that completes the
proof of theorem a I want to make some
remarks about about this proof and the
statement
[Applause]
okay so what are some remarks
Wow now this happens so one is you you
see from this proof so so from this
proof actually this polynomial while it
appears to depend on the entire
distribution of the random vectors are I
only depends on the covariance matrices
only depends on the expectations of RI
RI transpose the one remark is that the
expected characteristic polynomial the
sum of independent rank one random
matrices probably depends on the
covariance matrices
what that means is I can actually just
define this to be a function of the
covariance matrices so this is going to
come up again in the next lecture it's
sort of a useful class of polynomials so
I can define for positive semi-definite
matrices a1 through a.m. i can define mu
of a1 through a.m. we the expected
characteristic polynomial of a summation
of independent rank one random matrices
where these random vectors are drawn
from a distribution which has covariance
matrix AI that's what this means is not
a standard notation and this is called a
mixed characteristic polynomial
and this class of polynomials okay
certainly it was useful in in in the
proof we just saw of existence of
Brahmanism graphs
via signings but it includes a lot of
other objects at various different kinds
of people think about as special cases I
sort of just list them so what does this
do so this generalizes the matching
polynomial by the reduction mentioned in
Yuans lecture that if you if you look at
this adjacency matrix of assigning
shifted by D times the identity you get
one of these polynomials
it also generalizes another type of
polynomial if you evaluate this at a
bunch of identities you get it or you
get a generalized Legare polynomial
which is a type of orthogonal polynomial
the right so this is a polynomial in X
right so some okay I'm using Kyah to
mean characteristic polynomial and X
what's the platter that looks like for
this yeah the one that looks like for
this one looks like four oh that ah this
yeah oh it's supposed to be mu
the last coefficient of this polynomial
if you plug in two positive
semi-definite matrices the constant term
is the mixed discriminant it appears
when you're studying mixed volumes of
ellipsoid so those are some things that
are included in this class the second
thing I want to say about this proof or
the theorem and the proofs that are
presented is that I used independence in
a pretty heavy way right like when I was
doing this expansion when I went from
here to here I really use the fact that
the random vector is right-handed and
you could ask is this independence
really necessary and so okay so so you
can't completely let go of independence
because if you do that if the theorem
becomes kind of meaningless so let me
just say that independence is necessary
so some form of independence is
necessary because consider the following
example you know I could just look at
the characteristic polynomial of
I could look at the following two
characteristic polynomials there the
characteristic polynomials of identity
and minus the identity so you can either
view this as these are rank one matrices
but their distributions are correlated
so the Joint Distribution just chooses
both of them or you can view this as a
high rank matrix the video is
independent / rank one property is
necessary because if you look at this
example well these are each real rooted
but if you look at their average what
you get well this is you can X minus 1
squared plus X plus 1 squared times 1/2
which is x squared plus 1 which so you
need some some assumption like this and
these these assumptions really makes
sense together
so you have independent rank or
animators if you lose one you lose the
meaning of the other one however I
should mention that there's a result of
inari and Cheyenne where our 2014 which
says that you can relax independence
- negative dependence
and I'm not gonna define what that is
it's actually turns out to be the
strongly Rayleigh property which
Cheyenne's next lecture will be about so
you can relax this but you need some
sort of a sub probabilistic assumption
and this right core assumptions for this
tool so anyway these polynomials are
gonna come up again later tomorrow but
that completes the proof of the first
ingredient that I mentioned which is
what implied all of these real
rootedness statements that were used in
the proof that you are presented there's
any questions about that okay okay so
now I'll talk about the second more
quantitative part of the proof which was
a proof of this theorem of hominin liebe
of 1972 which says that if G is the
regular and it's and you define the
matching polynomial as yonder find it
I'm just writing it again just to remind
you
this is the number of matching the size
K then this polynomial has roots that
are bounded by this number two Square D
minus 1 which was the optimal bound for
this question of you know how small can
you make the second eigenvalue I mean
this is like you know it's a really old
theorem they were interested in
statistical physics they were interested
in the locations of zeros because this
polynomial after some change of
variables is a partition function of
some statistical physics model and the
location to the zeros say something
about phase transitions in this model
which I believe we'll also hear about
more about in the bootcamp that's the
statement of the theorem and you know
that this is the bound that eventually
gave you this this Robin isn't bound for
the graph now I'm going to explain a
proof of a theorem which implies this ok
so I'm not gonna tell you how many webs
original proof I'm gonna tell you a
proof of a theorem of God so which
implies this which is sort of really
illuminating and explains what this
number is so I mean the first time I saw
this and what a lot of people say
there's like what is this 2 Square D
minus 1 like who cares about this like
what does it mean but this proof of
explain was sort of explain what it
means okay so so what's the theorem of
God so to state the theory of God so I
need one more definition so the
definition is for a vertex are contained
in a graph let D sub G of R be the self
avoiding walk tree
rooted at our okay so rather than write
down some mathematical definition I'll
show you a picture which will make it
clear what the definition is so here's
here's a graph G
and I've labeled the vertices 1 2 3 4
that's G now let's say I want to find
the self avoiding walk tree rooted at
the vertex 1 so that's this vertex here
ok so the root it's a tree it's a finite
tree the root is just 1 the vertices of
the tree are indexed by self avoiding
walks in the graph a self avoiding walk
is just a walk that doesn't use any
vertex more than once I'm gonna have one
and then I'm gonna have one two and two
vertices in the self avoiding walk tree
are adjacent if one self avoiding walk
extends the other one so one two is the
supporting walk one two three is a
self-loading walk but then when I do one
two three there's nothing else I can do
there's no wall two three one okay
another option is I can do one three one
three and then maybe one three two and
then there is one for sort of self
avoiding walk trees for every graph and
for every vertex in the graph you get a
finite tree which could be exponentially
large but it's finite tree okay and what
I'm gonna be interested in is counting
closed walks in this tree okay so I'm
gonna define W sub G of our superscript
L to be the number of closed walks of
length L
so close just means it begins and ends
at the same vertex and that vertex is
our so rooted at our links this means
the number of vertices which is the same
as the number of edges cuz it's a cycle
so I'm gonna be interested in so this is
the new notation there's a self avoiding
walk tree inside itself avoiding walk
tree there's a count of these walks
which are not self avoiding walks
they're just any closed walks okay so
this so this includes things like you
know it includes let's say this walk so
I walk you know I just walk down here
and come back up but it also includes
walks like you know I go here I come
back I go here and come back then I go
here and I come back they're all
legitimate closed walks Moodle of
different links this has length 4
because 1 2 3 4 and this has length
something so what God's approved
is that the matching polynomial of a
graph it moments have a combinatorial
meaning so let lambda 1 to lambda and be
the roots of the matching polynomial sub
graph and let's assume the graph is
irregular
you just need bounded degree but let's
assume get regular then you look at the
moment so you look at the sums of powers
health powers of the roots these have a
very nice common toriel meaning there
it's the the elta moment of the roots is
simply the total number of closed walks
in all path trees of length L ok so I'm
gonna call this tree like walks but the
sum over all choices of root in the
graph of the number of walks routed of
length L rooted at that vertex
so I'm gonna call these tree like walks
that's what God so called them
any questions about the statement yeah I
know it's 0fl is odd this is zero so the
matching polynomial whose roots are
symmetric about zero so the odd moments
are 0 and indeed if you earn a tree and
you look at it doesn't have odd cycles
as bipartite so indeed yes I mean I walk
in this this tree induces some walk in
the graph right is the is the reason for
this tree like name that that walk never
goes around a cycle I mean this
introduces a subclass of walks in the
graph it's not every walk in the graph
is a tree like look no but a fixed what
if I take a walk in the tree yeah it
uses a particular walk in the graph yeah
will be cycle free right well no I mean
it depends on how you're defined cycle
cuz you're allowed to zigzag here right
no you can zigzag in the graph also so I
mean there is a way to define it
intrinsically in the graph it's this
sort of annoying you have to define
irreducible cycles and whatnot but this
is some subclass of walks in the in the
graph I mean maybe some people prefer
the graph the straight up definition
from the graph I've always just found it
easier to think about it
but yeah okay so okay so why do we care
about this and what does it have to do
with the hilemon web theorem well
there's an exercise which you will do
later which says that the number of tree
like walks rooted at any vertex of
length L this grows it as two squared B
minus one plus little o of one this is
just a statement about the infinite tree
I mean one way to you know if you want
you could sandwich the infinite tree in
here you can sandwich this by the number
of walks of length L from a root of
length in an infinite tree right so in
any this is a finite tree the number of
closed walks in the finite trees at most
whatever it is if you made it an
infinite tree and then this is just some
common toriel exercise what you will do
and you'll get to the bar okay so the
asymptotic growth rate of these type of
walks is two squared divides one into
that okay and so what's the upshot well
the upshot is if you let L go to
infinity in this inequality well what
does it mean well you know this grows as
maybe n times 2 root D minus 1 to the L
and that has to matter that the largest
root cannot grow any any faster than 2
Square D - yeah we have lambda one of
the matching polynomial
is at most you know n times this to root
D minus one plus the low of one to the L
and you take else roots you take L to be
huge this implies lambda 1.is it most is
two square root that's why this number
comes from it comes from counting walks
and infinity very tree okay let me prove
this result any any questions respect
let's prove this
is this marker getting kind of harder to
see maybe I'll switch to another okay so
I want to relate this thing on the
left-hand side which is some analytic
looking quantity related to moment to
the roots of the polynomial to this
combinatorial quantity on the right hand
side
so the the key ingredient in the proof
which I'm going to use is some very
simple recurrences satisfied by the
matching polynomial that follow almost
immediately from the definition so the
key ingredient is some recurrences and
this is this is sort of a prototype of a
type of argument that people use to
bound roots of combinatorial we define
polynomials they find some recurrences
and that's how they get a handle on the
roots so what are the recurrence is
there are two simple ones so one is if
you take the matching polynomial of a
graph and differentiate it you just get
the sum of matching polynomials of the
vertex deleted graphs over all choices
of the deleted vertex
either both exercises they're kind of
trivial they might even be too easy but
anyway and the second is a vertex
tuition recurrence it says that the
matching polynomial of a graph so for
any vertex are in the graph you can
write the matching polynomial as x times
the nicing polynomial with that vertex
we did plus I'm sorry minus the sum over
all neighbors of the vertex matching
polynomial with both of our seats with
these are easy to prove here you
basically ask well which terms
correspond to matchings containing R and
which correspond to matchings containing
R and which correspond to my things that
don't contain our and you get this so
these are this is what we're gonna use
to get a handle on the roots to prove
that identity
okay so how do you get how do you get a
handle on the moments of the roots so
well I mean okay the easiest way is to
observe that there's a very simple
generating function for the moment to
the roots
this log derivative of the polynomial so
if you look at the polynomial divided by
itself this has come up a bunch of times
already and I mean I guess if you've
worked in this area you know that this
is the first thing you should look at
well this is sum of 1 over X minus
lambda i if i you know if i factor
polynomial as this way then this is sort
of this is immediate and now I can pull
a 1 over X out so let me just do that
here 1 over X 1 - ok now we can expand
this as a power series and see that I
get that this is summation i equal to 0
summation lambda I to the L over X to
the L
so the this rational function is a
generating function for the moment to
the roots that's one that's one side of
it that's the quantity on the left hand
side on the other hand by the first
recurrence I can also write this so I
can expand the derivative of the sum of
matching polynomials of vertex deleted
graphs
I'll get that this is summation over all
R and T of the matching polynomial with
are deleted divided by the matching
and so now looking at this picture I
wanted to show that these coefficients
you know counting walks counting tree
like walks rooted are all the possible
vertices in the graph well it would be
sufficient to show a local version of
this statement which is that for every
vertex in the graph this rational
function the rational function you get
by the wheel by dividing the vertex to
advancing polynomial by matching for
Gnomeo itself counts three like walks
but only rooted at the vertex are
if I could prove this that I could just
add this up over all vertices and I
would get that it's equal to that and
that's what's written over here right at
the moment is the sum over all vertices
at the number of real icons by comparing
coefficients I would immediately get oh
I'm sorry X to the L by comparing
coefficients of X to the L I will get
okay any questions so far I mean now I'm
just going to prove
okay so how do you know this we've the
statement here how do you prove the
statement star well hey let's write this
down
and let's apply the second recur so here
we applied the first recurrence we have
another occurrence to write that you can
express this in terms of its vertex
deleted nicing Portimao so let's do the
natural thing let's apply the second
recurrence to the denominator we're
writing X just to save
this means via neighbor of our
okay clearly some stuff cancels I get
that this is one over X -
it's kind of nice I expressed one of
these ratios in terms of some similar
ratios but in a smaller graph right here
I just deleted are and here I deleted V
in addition to our comparative to just
ignore okay
so now I expand this is the power series
get 1 over X information okay I'll get 1
over X the answer to our
so in the background here you know you
should be forming a picture that there's
a vertex here R and you know it has some
that some neighbors these V's and I'm
expressing these ratios of interest
which apparently are going to be
counting these tree like walks in terms
of similar ratios but now one step down
in the tree so now what do I do
well now I use induction right this is a
graph with one verse vertex reduction
assuming the formula holds for smaller
graphs I get that this is 1 over X
nation K greater than equal to 0 okay
and bear with me this is a single this
is ugly as display of this proof and I
know that you know it has this sort of
it might freak you out but every piece
of it has sort of a nice meaning so you
have the 1 over X and now I apply the
induction hypothesis here I have 1 over
X to the K that just comes out of here
and now I'm saying this thing itself
satisfies this property so this is
itself for 1 over X deviation tree like
walks but now in this vertex weighted
graph
oh I'm sorry there should be a summation
over the vertices
it's all I did is I replaced this
quantity by this because that's the
induction hypothesis
okay and now I mean okay are you may be
wondering is this a mess or is this is
this good huh everything is raised to
the power okay yeah okay and now I'm
going to write this in a slightly more
suggestive way this is 1 over X
summation K greater than or equal to
zero so I have a 1 over X to the K here
1 over X to the K from here so I have 1
over X to the 2k and now I have a
product of K sums so let me just write
them as separate sums with different
indices the summation over v1 incident
are yeah the wok generating function
over that v1
with length l-1
then the same thing for v2 and then
eventually the same thing for VK
okay so I've not done anything I just
said this is a power let me introduce a
variables and write it as a KY
Department okay now what do you do with
this will you make one combinatorial
observation and see that it's exactly
what you want so what did we want well
we want this thing to be equal if
everything worked out what would we want
this to be we would want this to be 1
over x times you know what we what's
written over there just the sum over we
like walks routed at and my original
route our
so are these things equal okay so let me
make let me draw a picture and you'll
see that they're equal so here's the
observation so there's a root right so
here we have tree like walks in our tree
like walks through dessert are here we
have tree like walks rooted at neighbors
of our in a graph for our has been
deleted the observation is well think
about a tree like walk rooted at our
think about a tree like walk through
tour that visits the route exactly K
times what does it look like well first
it goes down to some some vertex v1 then
it does something there and it goes back
then it goes down to some other vertex V
2 then it does something there then it
goes back and it does this K times
that's what we like walk with exactly K
excursions looks like so the observation
is a walk in the true dirt at this
vertex are
is defined by how do you define to walk
well you have to have two ingredients
one is I'm sorry walk in this thing
with exactly K visits to are it's
defined by a sequence of K neighbors we
want to be K of our so that's these
these first vertices you see after the
excursion and then what do you do inside
this excursion you take a tree like walk
starting at V but with one constraint
you can't visit Oregon right so tree
like walks
got my eye in the set of three like
walks rooted at vertices VI but in the
graph with are deleted of length Li such
that well the lengths of all everything
has to add up to L right so the lengths
of these excursions l1 l2 up to L K plus
2 K must be equal to K so such that this
summation of the lengths of these
excursions is equal to K L minus 2 K
that's so simple if you were scared by
the power series just focus on this this
is something we can all agree on
hopefully you take oh we like walk it
consists of excursions and this is how
you count now if you compare the powers
of X to the L here and here that's
exactly what's going on right so so this
this K visit this corresponds to this K
in the sum so let's see what say you fix
K so it consists of a sequence of v1
through VA choice of K vertices that's
going on right here and you're
multiplying them together so that means
your make you're multiplying all the
different possibilities and inside each
one you're taking a local walk in the
vertex weighted graph so that I don't
know how what notation to use for this
but okay this corresponds to this and
indeed if you look at the coefficient of
x to the L you're gonna have out some of
L I is plus 2 K equals L so indeed you
get exactly so it's not I mean it you
know it's you have to be careful but
it's not I mean for such a I don't know
for I think such a beautiful result it
it's quite a relatively simple proof
okay you have to do the base case I
didn't do the base case the base case is
easy but I mean the point of showing you
this was that this is this is a type of
argument that comes up a lot in this
area you have some combinatorial
polynomial you have a recurrence you use
it to expand
this rational function often in some way
and you you do some combinatoric sand
you can get some bounce moments and
things like that okay so any questions
about this proof is there by detective
what well okay so I erase the statement
but I'm not by jacking walks with
matchings right I'm showing that the the
walks accounting walks is the same as
computing powers of roots which are not
combinatorial quantities that's what's
so remarkable about this like you go on
MATLAB you write down these polynomials
to compute the roots you add up their
squares you get an integer you know
that's not something that happens in
directly so the power subs are related
to the coefficients and this is how you
prove newton's identities to essentially
your the examine this function and you
could you could prove it you could try
to prove it using Newton's identities
but it's a lot uglier you could but
anyway in my opinion this is the easiest
way to prove new to the identities you
take a polynomial you took at P prime by
P you expand it in power series and you
expander and coefficients and you
compare the coefficient
okay that's that's what I want to say
about God so proof now what does this
have to do with algorithm so I mentioned
algorithms and say a little bit about
algorithms any more questions about this
[Music]
thing's I mean usually the simplest
reason why something's an integer is
it's counting something right I mean as
far as I know I don't know unless
somebody else has Oh are these moments
traces of matrix powers yes so then so
you can use this technology to prove
that I mean well I don't know we are we
sort of are proving that right if you
can make a matrix out of these trees and
then the trace of the power will count
actually it's not the trace its rooted
walks so there are trace of a matrix
power
I don't know anything I don't actually
don't know what a natural does anybody
else
okay okay that's why this two squared D
minus one comes from it counting the
growth we're walks in a tree okay so
what
so maybe before so they say what's a
summary so so there is a multivariate
version of this which i think is done by
Nick and Jonathan I don't know so what
do you mean by trace of the power yeah I
think what you're saying is if you do
partial with respect so there's a
multivariate version of this all this
works with multivariate if instead of
differentiating in X you differentiate
in one of the variables then that's it's
not the trace that's what I'm saying
it's just not right so if you make this
self avoiding walk tree you don't
literally computer its trace you compute
the number of walks rooted at the root
you don't add up the walks loser at all
the vertices so it's not literally a
trace this is a diagonal and really it's
a diagonal entry yeah that's what I
meant for us it was not a trace
okay so so what's the summary of what
just happened in this and the last talk
well we showed that in the so if you're
interested in finding signings of a d
regular graph well we showed you're
interested in finding signings with
small largest eigenvalue well we showed
that for all signings as n goes to
infinity that has to be at least two
squared B minus one minus little one
that's the Elan gopano bound it can't
beat this but then we showed there
exists a signing using interlacing which
gets the largest root of the matching
polynomial and then we showed using this
how this god seller home and we've
argument that this is at most two
squared D minus one and now these these
if you understand the prove alone but
find out which you will understand after
you do the homework and you see that
these are both counting walks and then
three that's what two squared D minus
one meet okay so about algorithms so
oh I started like two minutes late right
but maybe I'll finish with him so so one
observation what the reason I presented
this proof as opposed to some other
proofs of this bound that this proof
gives you an algorithm for approximating
roots of mass component so the else
moment of the of the roots is equal to
these walks right okay I took out to
infinity to find the largest route
exactly but if you take L equal to log n
over epsilon then let's call this
quantity M sub L of lambda then then you
get that M sub L of lambda is within 1
plus or minus epsilon of the largest
root that's an easy exercise computer
high enough moment it's like that one
for Eddie norm but now the point is you
can compute the right-hand side for L
equal to log in or epsilon right now
compute right-hand side by enumerating
else moment log in a rep cilantro oh I'm
sorry
okay I'm just defining this as a power
ah okay yeah let's do this
thank you
so so you can compute this by
enumerating three like walks and how
much time does that take well it's a
bounded degree graph so it takes time
about n times D to the log n over
epsilon which is actually polynomial for
about the degree so all the suffering
was to the suffering was just to explain
the tour D minus one yeah but
quasi-polynomial yeah so you're right
so okay if you if you're okay with
putting an end to the log n you don't
have to do any of the suffering there's
a much simpler way to do it I'm sorry I
hope it had some redeeming value in
addition to the computation because this
is not that hard I agree but so this
gives you a PETA's or lambda one but you
know the dependence on the error is
horrible and this is not good enough to
make the interlacing argument
constructive because in the interlacing
argument rubber you had this tree you
had a binary tree where at every step
you were choosing you know plus 1 or
minus 1 for the first edge and then
maybe for the second edge and so on what
this is saying is you can you can make
the right decision up to an error of
plus or minus epsilon where epsilon the
constant so that's horrible right
because you're gonna if you do this for
M steps you're gonna pick up an error of
plus or minus M epsilon edges so this
doesn't give you an algorithm let me
finally just say what Michael Cohen did
so he did get an algorithm based on a
different approach to this problem
so this okay so I'm by the way I think
this is a good open question is there an
FB TAS with the largest root of masking
polynomial nothing problem we have FP
testers rather counting problems is
there one for this if you if you could
get the dependence on this to be
polynomial whatever epsilon you would
get well and you could do it for the
conditional polynomials you would get
another degree there what degree for the
for the conditional polynomials so I
meant for the construction of revenues
and graphs as per Yuans lecture so okay
what do you have to do you have to come
approximate largest roots of all of the
polynomials in the inner racing tree oh
no I didn't say that yes okay that's
also a question yeah so an open question
is to improve the dependence here to
follow me over epsilon which i think
would be quite interesting and since it
counts something you maybe have a chance
of doing ok so last I just want to talk
about this alternate approach that's not
based on lifts or signings or whatever
the alternate approach roughly is
instead of doing any of the stuff just
consider a random regular graph G is a
union d random perfect matchings
so you have some bipartition of to and
vertices and you just pick I don't know
you you pick a perfect matching you pick
d of them
you take the Union you get a graph the
agency matrix of the graph is concretely
it's a sum of conjugations of the
adjacency matrix of a matching with D
random permutations is e 1 to P D are
independent random permutations on this
by partition in the natural way so then
there's a theorem which we proved with
Marcus and Spielman which says that even
in this setting this is not a sum of
independent rank order either matrices
it's something actually different we
proved is that the whole interlacing
thing works out in this case two namely
the largest eigenvalue is the second
eigen value of this matrix a is at most
the second root of the expected
characteristic polynomial with nonzero
probability and the second root is at
most two squared D minus one by some
arguments involving free probability
which I won't have any time to discuss
so I'll just drop the buzzword and if
you want to talk about it later talk
about it
and what Cohen did is he came up Michael
Cohen came up with an interlacing family
that bruises remember the way you proved
these statements is by starting with
your expected polynomial and slowly
conditioning it to get a real polynomial
in some sort of a tree you constructed
an interlacing tree that's very
different from what we did and from
what's not on the other paper the
decisions in the tree are well the root
is the expected characteristic
polynomial the first level you choose
the neighbor of the first vertex in the
first matching so let's label these
vertices we want to V n there are n
choices in the field n polynomials of
common air racing in the second level
you have degree you have n minus 1
choices you choose the neighbor V 2 in
the perfect in the first matching so on
and you do this for every matching so
first you choose the first matching that
in each of the second matching then you
choose the third matching and finally
choose D matching so the depth is d
times n you have D of these matchings he
constructed an interlacing family that
proves this and he proved that you can
exactly compute all these polynomials in
polynomial time
there's no approximation even literally
I mean we proved that the top one
actually as a formula but he he proved
that you I mean has a very beautiful
technique she's extremely clever where
he showed that so you can exactly the
expected characteristic polynomial and
all the conditional ones
in polynomial time
so that's how that's a very high-level
an idea about how it works but maybe the
point I wanted to make is that these
interlacing families are not unique
there if you could if you have one
existence argument for this you may be
able to construct a different tree which
has very different computational
properties our original tree everything
was sharply hard and we had to go
through all this song and dance to get
some sort of crappy approximation
algorithm but for this tree you can
compute everything exactly
[Applause]